u.s. presidential hopeful Joe Biden is
speaking out for the first time about
allegations of sexual assault involving
a former employee former Vice President
Biden told MSNBC he did not assault then
staffer Tara Reid when he when she
worked for him in 1993 when he was the
senator he said he couldn't remember her
making a complaint Reid says Biden
touched her inappropriately and sexually
assaulted her I'm joined now by White
House correspondent Kimberly how did so
Kimberly how crucial will be what turns
up in the National Archive to how this
goes yeah well after weeks of silence
and pressure by his own party members to
respond the Democratic presumptive
Democratic presidential nominee former
Vice President Joe Biden is now speaking
out denying that this sexual assault
ever take took place as Tara Reid is
claiming and he's now calling on the
National Archives to release her
complaint if it even exists now these
allegations stem back to 1993 when the
former vice president was a senator on
Capitol Hill Tara Reid was an aide in
his office she alleges that he pushed
her against the wall and sexually
assaulted her
her friends are corroborating her story
but now the question becomes whether or
not that complaint was filed and exists
so the former Vice President Joe Biden
has responded in a statement he says
well the details of these allegations of
sexual harassment and sexual assault are
complicated two things are not
complicated one is that women deserve to
be treated with dignity and respect and
when they step forward they should be
heard not silenced the second is that
their stories should be subject to
appropriate inquiry and scrutiny and
that is what the spotlight is on now
whether or not this complaint exists and
what the fallout shall be if it is
discovered all right now stay with us
Kimberly because we have a shot here we
should listen in to what Joe Biden was
saying
no it is not true I'm saying
unequivocally it never never happened it
it didn't it never happened do you
remember her do you remember any any
types of complaints that she might have
made I don't remember any type of
complaint she may have made it was 27
years ago and I don't remember nor does
anyone else that I'm aware of and the
fact is that I don't remember
I don't remember any complaint ever
having been made Kimberly how
problematic does this look like it could
be to the whole Biden campaign well
there are a couple of things at play
here number one times have changed in
the air of the me2 movement what was
acceptable 27 years ago is not
acceptable now so that's the first
problem for the former vice president
but the other issue in all of this is
and something that works in his favor is
that he's not the only high-profile
politician to have very serious
allegations against him you remember the
allegations against President Trump on
the campaign trail in 2016 in fact he's
had more than mud 20 women accuse him of
some form of sexual advance and he has
denied these repeatedly in fact the US
president talked about this late
Thursday when he almost defended the
former Vice President Joe Biden saying
that he should respond but they could be
false accusations that he's facing and
Trump said he knows of this well because
again he has been accused repeatedly he
also brought up the case of the supreme
court justice judge Cavanaugh Brett
Kavanaugh his confirmation hearings
where he was also the president says
falsely accused but this is certainly a
difficult issue that the former vice
president joe biden is going to have to
confront and it won't go away quickly
but already there are many on his side
including the House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
on Capitol Hill she has not responded
since this tape has come out but she
said previously that she was satisfied
with Joe Biden's denials and considered
him a person of an
Haggerty all right thanks so much
Kimberly how did bad